esta vacuna tiene una efectividad de
entre el 30 y el 50 por ciento que es
relativamente baja pero que hay que
decirle a la población para que confíe
en el fármaco
bueno es muy importante tener presente
que la vacuna va a ayudar dentro del
contexto de lo que son los esfuerzos de
los programas de control de malaria lo
cual quiere decir que no es una
estrategia aislada sino que se suma en
particular a todo el conjunto de otras
estrategias de prevención que tiene la
enfermedad
doctor rodríguez morales la vacuna para
combatir esta enfermedad ya se había
creado hace varias décadas porque solo
hasta ahora la mente da su aprobación a
una de ellas
bueno tiene que ver justamente con el
desempeño por lo que se ha observado en
los programas pilotos que ha venido
evaluando la organización mundial de la
salud recientemente pues se observa que
en algunos de los países de áfrica esta
vacuna ha tenido realmente beneficios y
en esa evaluación entonces y el de la
necesidad por supuesto de la importancia
que tiene la malaria
pues se dio aprobación con el fin ahora
de ver luego de esta aprobación cuáles
van a ser los efectos también que tiene
en el comportamiento de la misma lo que
llamamos la efectividad en el mundo real
ya con la aplicación masiva de esta
vacuna como está siendo recomendado en
este momento áfrica también ha sufrido
el retraso en el suministro de la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 de las más de 6 mil
millones de dosis administradas en el
mundo sólo el 2% ha llegado al
continente según cifras recientes que
podemos esperar ahora del fármaco contra
la malaria
bueno son escenarios diferentes hay que
tener presente que la lucha contra la
malaria lleva muchísimo tiempo en el
continente africano especialmente hay
muchísimas instituciones no solamente la
organización mundial de la salud sino en
particular otros agentes regionales
muchas universidades centros de
investigación y lo que se espera
realmente detrás de los grupos que están
apoyando a esto es que se pueda lograr
lo más rápidamente posible masificar
justamente la aplicación amén de eso por
supuesto también en el contexto de kobe
seguir en el contexto de incrementar las
coberturas de vacunación también para el
joven 19 doctor conocemos el impacto que
ha tenido la malaria en áfrica pero cuál
es la situación que se registra en
américa latina' con esta enfermedad
américa latina está enfrentando también
un problema muy complejo especialmente a
expensas de la situación sanitaria de la
crisis que diez países como el caso de
venezuela donde venezuela ha venir a una
situación de descontrol no ha aplicado
correctamente los planes y los programas
no solamente de malaria sino de otras
enfermedades que pueden ser de hecho
prevenibles por vacunas y
lamentablemente pues se han dado
aumentos muy notables de la enfermedad
los últimos años que además impactan a
otros países de la región como ocurre
con los casos importados a colombia
brasil y de hecho incluso a países muy
distantes en el cono sur como chile y
argentina